it's okay it's still big okay right here
it's the little bruising
[Music]
of course it's smaller than previously
but it's still big it's still a triple d
okay michael was in shock
he's in shock speechless
after seeing angela's breast reduction
for the first time
this was angela's worst fear i mean i
was shocked at their size too
but he could have had the decency to
hide it
she just got out of surgery he was a
total ass
at the beginning of this angela did warn
me about michael's behavior
but i didn't think he was going to do
her like that
men out there tell me something do you
understand
michael's reaction because i don't
it just has me thinking as a woman what
do you do in a situation like this
it's not like you went to the hair salon
and you changed your hair and your man
doesn't like your hair
no this is your body we're gonna talk
about it
just take me home plus julia storms out
during dinner with brandon's friend
melanie
after she started voicing her opinion
too much i just feel like
maybe um y'all maybe rushed into it way
too quickly
i'm curious do you think julia
overreacted
or was little miss melanie being messy
maybe she's using him at this point i
think i might go with the latter
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
this episode i felt bad for angela
it was actually kind of sad because on
top of an extremely painful surgery
okay i'm gonna use some pain
michael showed his behind
when he really could have kept it
together
my boobs are gone following angela's
procedure
yes she was upset when she saw her
breasts for the first time
i'm not very happy i want to know what
the hell happened mainly because she
knew
michael would have a fit i haven't
spoke to michael since my surgery
because
at this point right now i'm scared to
death to show michael
my boobs she was scared for the truth to
come out
which is that michael cares a little bit
too much about those things
come on in doc how are we doing they
look small
you look small apparently dr obang took
two pounds out of each
breast when he told angela he was only
gonna take out
one pound yeah but i mean i don't see
nobody
please don't look nothing uh-uh i don't
think that's funny
please don't look nothing
i'm not gonna lie i will feel some type
of way if he did that to me too
although his logic does make sense once
everything comes down it's gonna be big
basically he says once she starts losing
weight due to the gastric sleeve
her boobs won't seem so small after all
and then maybe we can show
you can show michael the top no have you
spoken to him yet
no dr obang talked angela into
finally calling michael and what she got
was exactly what she expected a husband
who started to question everything now
all because his wife's body changed
the sad thing about this is that there
are probably way too many women
who can relate
of course it's smaller than previously
but it's still big it's still a triple d
dr obang was like this is awkward okay
here you take the phone
and damn angela didn't even want to turn
the camera back around
although angela's a tough cookie to hear
something like this from michael
it's hurtful you upset
[Music]
but this is hell hazard okay they were
very heavy
michael we need to stop going los
angeles why the angel their personality
not their physical attribute preach dr
obang
i couldn't say nothing because i'm
mentally
physically exhausted but he ought to
think how much better i can breathe
without him
and that's the truth i can breathe much
better so maybe i did the right thing
you definitely did this is so
revealing because if someone truly loved
you
in a moment like this they would be
trying to make you feel better about
yourself
not worse now i don't expect too much
out of this relationship because it's so
unusual
i'll just say that but you would at
least expect michael to show some
compassion for angela being in the state
that she's in
no matter how turned off he is if
michael divorces me with my boobs
and you did it so does that mean you'll
marry me i can't marry you because
you're my patient
i
one thing you have to love about angela
is that
you can't break her and here comes dr
obang with the perfect curve
he's not going to divorce you if he
divorce he will find somebody
well i spoke to angela not too long ago
and based off of what she told me
this is just the beginning of michael
turning on her
if you could describe it in one word how
has this year been for you and michael
hale is that
is it a hell and we are coming back or
is it just
you're still burning in hell what is it
well
you know you have to watch and see the
outcome but um
with the surgeries and all and um
you know i i i i don't know if i can say
this but at one point you know i was
telling michael
somehow you changed since we got married
and we're not even living together yet
like don't take that for granted because
there's always a
damn divorce court right around the
corner michael i mean we went to hell we
literally went through hell and uh it
was it was bad and you'll see that
well apparently next week she has a new
secret to tell michael which
i can't wait to hear i got something
else to tell you
damn tell me check me out all right
let's talk julia and brandon so tonight
julie and i are gonna go out and we're
gonna meet my friend melanie and her
boyfriend
and we're just gonna have dinner
together and get some drinks and hang
out
yeah so fun okay so we know julia has a
jealousy issue that she needs to work on
she didn't want to hang out with
brandon's friend because because like
brandon girl this is like
people she's a girl and julia doesn't
like
any women around brandon unless it's
betty
and half of the time she doesn't even
like that now based off the teas we got
last week
coming into this episode i assumed that
julia was going to be totally
in the wrong but melanie and we were
friends in high school
and we've contended our friendship till
now
she rubbed me the wrong way too so while
julia
did overreact yes she did because that's
just what she does sometimes
i also understand why she got so upset
and left
what do we do in the farm huh what'd we
do in the pharmacy
when they first started talking there
were moments where julia's jealousy
did pop out which wasn't cool
but melanie played into it by giving
julia details she didn't need to know
what was that movie that we stayed up
all night watching it's like a scary one
yes see there is a line of respect that
you just don't cross
when it comes to people who are in
relationships she could have really kept
that part to herself about them staying
up
all night julia didn't need to know that
it's like she wanted her to feel some
type of way
what brought you all together on top of
the unnecessary details
melanie thought this dinner her first
time meeting julia
was the right moment to give her opinion
on their relationship
mind you this girl hasn't been around
for two years
i just feel like maybe um y'all maybe
rushed into it way too quickly
i mean doesn't it seem like you know you
may be scared that one day she's gonna
be like okay well
i mean i'm done i got my visa and i'm
good
i don't want his heart to get broken and
i just want to make sure that this is
like
exactly what you want one that's not
your place
two melanie you are late to the party
this conversation has been had with the
people who matter most to him
they live with his parents either way
she continued
i do know that there's a lot of people
coming to america just
um to meet a guy just so they can stay
here and get a visa and stuff
i mean like if i use you for green card
i not tell you i use him for green card
i guess that's true you probably
wouldn't say it if you
i mean i feel like you should care about
like what his friends think about him
should she and how close of friends are
you really
you found out he got married on facebook
honestly um
the first time that i really saw
that they were together was through
social media
and i was like wow when did this happen
melanie's last comment about the green
card
was the final straw for julia she told
her it was none of her business and then
she exploded if you won't take time is
your fight
you just seem normal i'm normal
why are you acting like this why these
people ask me more questions
such stupid questions like i found your
green card here
and a guy we care about brain i'm your
friend
i tell you this is not a good idea with
your call her friend
just take me home and that he did
brandon should have spoken up for julia
he allowed
melanie to sit there and interrogate her
this is your wife now dude oh my gosh so
many memories
after watching all of this i must say
julia might have been on to something
melanie could have a secret thing for
brandon
it's possible brandon's um always had a
type
they've always kind of looked like julia
very thin
um burnett very bossy julia definitely
fits that
and so do you they've always kind of
looked like julia
very thin burnett very bossy
all right well next week it looks like
julia might be getting that green card
that was the topic of conversation we
got a letter today
from who it's from the united states uh
so excited and they're so nervous
because you know what it is
it's really green in there we'll see
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t
because we are covering it all i will
see you next time
[Music]